whether it's playoff time first game of
the season
whatever it is you know you throw the
ball up i'm gonna come down with it this
is it number 10
stutter to the corner got it
man i'm sweating my butt off madden you
better up my rating
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of underrated i'm your host adam lefkow
if you've watched football for the last
half decade it should not surprise you
that alan robinson has some top flight
madden ratings
and if you've seen commercials during
that time you probably also know
that state farm has surprisingly great
rates
back to alan robinson we got to get
those ratings higher
and i got a madden ratings adjuster to
talk to hey jake
get madden on the phone calling madden
readings
adjuster mr oldenburg i
presume not wasting any time alan
robinson do you agree with me he's
underrated
i mean it's possibly could be underrated
he has played with some
not always the best quarterbacks i'm
glad you understand that we don't even
have to say their names let's call up
alan robinson
hey jake call best friend alan robinson
calling alan robinson
alan robinson only i don't know the most
underrated wide receiver
in the nfl how you doing pal i'm good
man how you doing adam
honestly i'm a little annoyed i was
looking at your madden ratings and i saw
where they had you
and as a very good friend i cannot let
that slide
but i am here to fix it allen this is
clint oldenburg
he is the madden ratings adjuster clint
what would you like to say to alan
ooh alan robinson one of my favorite
players uh what do you got for me today
i like alan a lot all right well let's
get to the numbers here
first one no one talks about it stamina
i mean look at this collection of 90s we
got jumping
acceleration heck even awareness which
means they think that you're really
smart
i just have no idea why stamina isn't
there with everything else
i have no idea either on madden i've
seen it your character
is bent over huffing and puffing and
ready to come out
clean second one spectacular catches
i've seen this dude catch balls off the
helmet
what do i do to get that up spec catch
popular rating
uh simply put gotta make amazing happen
we gotta see these
you know wow moments that occur in
madden gotta see those in real life
whether it's playoff time first game of
the season college whatever it is you
know you throw the ball up i'ma come
down with it
make amazing happen clint i'll talk to
you soon
so alan i've seen you play you wear down
corners you're not the one getting worn
down so what we're gonna do
is a bit of a hurry up offense we're
gonna start on the five
and if you can outlast your madden
character
i think we can get the stamina rating
bumped up big time sounds good
we have assembled this fine team right
here together
you'll quickly march down the field no
timeouts
no rest we are up in my man's ratings
today most definitely let's get it done
sweat is already dripping i love it
all right here we go alan
up stop good catch all right let's get
going
no stopping you got this baby
another one up in
made him get down and get it on that one
too same place
snap to the quarterback allen caught it
turning up field the bears are
moving the chains up in
that one was high incomplete pass
oh he's got a run block by the way it is
really hot there
and i am in air conditioning so
dime we're good
this is where his madden character would
start huffing and puffing
now slant caught moving the chains
same play that you just did face pace
throwing it nice did he get in the end
zone
no just down there at the one this is it
number 10
stutter to the corner
got it how are you feeling man that
looked exhausting feel great man i got
tim more in let's go man and boost that
stamina
and i mean you ended it with the perfect
touchdown a rob man gotta end it with a
little spectacular
catch action you know you must have read
my mind
how would you feel about making a
highlight reel of you recreating five
iconic nfl catches
sounds good to me
so who are you thinking first let's do
the randy moss one first
now you're talking my man the 2010
one-hander against rivas let's see it
is that alan moss or is that randy
robinson
all right we got that one down that one
felt great so who are you thinking next
let's do dwight
okay classic the catch for the 1981
nfc championship if you can give me all
42 inches of your vertical
i think it's over
[Applause]
what's your thoughts adam i think every
time you go up for a ball
it's coming down with alan robinson most
definitely that's what i like to hear
so next would be let's go san antonio
oh one of my favorites san antonio homes
in the end zone in the super bowl show
me how it's done
oh bro you went horizontal i think
that's the one man
i think that was the one for sure all
right add it to the highlight
so the last one is odell and this one's
a little crazy
that was my rookie year and i remember
thinking like that might not might be
that was
still probably to this day the craziest
catch i've actually seen so
i think if we give it our best three
attempts
i drop the most impressive one on the
reel and i'll send that to mata
i can do that i can do that i don't know
about you guys
but i feel a surprisingly great
spectacular catch coming up
oh too high man you gotta keep it down a
little bit but i like the idea
here we go everything on the line
man let her rip takes the snap
fires throws
[Applause]
and he hits it wow add it to the
highlight ea
sports in for a heck of a delivery so
alan
we showed the stamina we showed the
spectacular catches
do you think we did enough for the
ratings adjuster today
man i'm sweating my butt off madden you
better up my rating
and if they don't move i'm going to get
you on the phone with the adjuster
and we're going to take care of this man
to man sounds good man i appreciate it
all right we'll get it done man you got
my word
[Music]
clint i have not seen an athlete get
this sweaty for ratings before
the video looks great what did you think
of it it better be good
there was some work being done on this
video i hope you reward him i'm bringing
him on now you have to talk to him face
to face let's call up alan robinson
hey there he is big 12. clint you looked
at the tape
spectacular catch and stamina what did
you think about those two drills when
you're watching on tape
obviously great drills i really liked
how you made him go through a 10-play
drive
that was phenomenal okay explain that so
going up two points in stamina from 89
to 91
from the 24th rated wide receiver and
stamina now
at 15th place for wide receivers and
he's passed some you know amazing
players like aj green and adam thielen
in that area
you went from a plus to an a minus
got to keep just moving them all up all
right spec catch one you're going to get
a one point upgrade you're going from 94
to 95 so you're going from the 10th best
wide receiver
to uh you're now tied for the eighth
best wide receiver in spec catch
95's a hard a clint top eight
top eight okay that's good news that's a
good news that's what we worked for man
so we're going on the field
and now the big question is alan
robinson
underrated in the nfl world eleanor
robinson is absolutely
the most underrated player in the nfl
from a madden standpoint
allen robinson is a little bit
underrated alan
overall how does it feel to know
that you were underrated you know i
think it's fun you know i don't ever
think i've started the year off
at a 90 so i really take take take pride
and you know
see how those drills paid off i love it
when a good plan comes together
and it ends up being surprisingly great
and this
has been a surprisingly great episode of
underrated brought to you by the
surprisingly great rates of state farm
alan you're the man dude
[Music]
you like what you just saw subscribe to
bleacher report on youtube for more
underrated